Right. All right.
Happy Tuesday.
Welcome to this brave crew of folks in person and online.
My name is Eli Van Allen, and it's a privilege to be the session chair for this
session. Before I jump into any of the details, I just
want to point out for folks in the room,
God bless you all, first of all, for being here.
And second of all, there's this nifty QR code.
If you don't feel confident about coming to the microphone, which we definitely
wish you would do, and we're encouraging a lot of discussion, that's the way the
session is structured. You can actually use this QR code, submit your questions
online, and part of my job will be to try to keep track of them for when we get to
the Q&A session.
This session is intentionally designed to be interactive.
I'll have a brief introductory set of remarks, followed by
passing the baton to our two outstanding speakers.
And then after that, there'll be lots of time for dialogue and discussion on this
very important topic.
So with that,
let me switch over to my slides.
This one.
Great.
So again, just first for introductory purpose sakes, my name is Eli Van
Allen. I'm a medical oncologist at Dana-Farber, and my
focus scientifically is more on the space of AI as applied to more
translational research, but I have the privilege of serving as the chief of a
division called Population Sciences, which has a lot of purview and interest in the
space that we're going to talk about this afternoon.
And the goal here is to learn from our speakers and then have a dialogue amongst
each other about novel technologies and knowledge bases and how they
could be used to optimize success in clinical trials.
And so what I was tasked with in advance of setting up for the speakers was to set
the stage for where things currently are. Here briefly are my disclosures.
So
I thought I'd set the stage with a few different versions of illustrating this
challenge. And so this is one version of the problem.
This is a relatively recent report from over
1,000 cancer center programs looking at cancer study
participation broken up by the type of trial.
And you don't need to zoom in on too many details to
glean rather, that performance is poor across the board.
And to the credit of these authors, they actually broke up the different kinds of
trials to see, well, is there something different about participation and
enrollment in some types of studies versus others?
And frankly, it's pretty dismal all around.
And I think in the spirit of this meeting, which is in a lot of
respects around
translational research and treatment trials, biomarker-directed genomics and so
on and so forth. We're really suffering at a 7% rate, which is
certainly suboptimal. But that isn't the only way to illustrate the challenge,
and there's a lot of other ways to try to wrap one's head around it, and here's
just another version of framing the problem.
And this I took from a very provocative review on this topic for which the
citation is listed below. And here they were trying to actually
map out all of the different behaviors that are
required for a clinical provider in
cancer domains to basically prompt
towards getting to clinical trial referral and enrollment.
And they break things up into multiple different buckets, capability and
whether they're familiar with the context.
Do they have any discussion expertise on how to talk about trials, management
skills, motivation about is the risk-benefit
ratio for pursuing the trial worth it?
Are there incentives that are worth considering? Is there research culture?
And obviously some of these things might be a little bit tangential to this topic,
but in some respects, maybe not. And also then leads to the things that
are really about the opportunity. How are we going to navigate trial databases?
Down to even very practical matters.
Is this even easy to interrogate the platform in the first place?
Can doctors understand how to use the system?
Is there supportive infrastructure?
Is there resources allocated to all these things?
This is just a different way to frame the problem.
But this, of course, isn't the only way to frame it.
Another way, if we started with just raw stats, and then we went into
more subjective behavioral considerations.
A third way is a very practical one.
And this I took unintentionally-- I don't think it was the intent of the authors,
but as part of a different review on the topic of clinical
trial enrollment and precision oncology studies, they had these
infographic mapping out all of the different steps required
practically to enroll a patient on a trial and to monitor that patient
in the trial. And the goal here is not to go through every single one of these, but
rather just to illustrate in this microscopic font that there is an inordinate
amount of steps. It is extremely cumbersome.
It's very difficult to do, and it creates this burden
that has prevented people from enrolling on trials.
And then finally, the last way I wanted to just frame it before we pass the baton
over is to say that this has additional challenges
that really hit at some of the problems in this space.
This is just an example actually taken from one of the recent AACR reports,
taking three different cancer types, looking at the demographics of participation
broken up by self-reported race. And you'll see the
distribution for these various cancers for the
prevalence. But then you see the breakdown of that
in the context of participation rates in clinical trials.
And for each of these three diseases, you will see there's
unfortunate lack of representation amongst certain groups.
And that really has lots of consequences for downstream
interpretation and
applicability in the broader clinical sense.
And so in totality, there's a lot
of angst regarding the
overall participation rate in trials,
the manner in which the providers are expected to
consider, find, and then match to trials,
the way in which they practically have to execute the trials, and the way in which
we find the patients and the relevant biomarkers that are needed to put them
on the right trials in the first place.Which is to say, we have a lot of work to
do.
And so,
no pressure, but just setting that stage for there, we're thrilled to have two
outstanding speakers who are going to talk about some of these issues and
some of the work that's happening in this space on a variety of fronts.
And I think the title of the session was sort of intentionally broad to sort of
help folks cover whatever was exciting to them.
And so with that, we have Laura Mangravite,
formerly of Digitalis Commons, and Deb Schrag
from Sloan Kettering, formerly
of Dana-Farber. Thanks, Deb.
And we're thrilled that you both are here.
So with that, I'll first pass the baton to Laura, who will take it from here.
All right, great. Thanks. It's wonderful to be here.
So I come to this problem from the perspective
of a data technologist. So
I used to run an organization called Sage Bionetworks, who was
based
in the development of data and knowledge bases for problems such as
this, right? And so we did work with Project Genie at AACR,
cBioPortal, et cetera, several of the knowledge bases involved in the
space. Most recently, I've been at Digitalis Commons.
This is the nonprofit sister arm to a ventures firm, and I was
very intentionally there to look at innovations that sit at the
intersection between the private and the public sector, for which I think
clinical trial infrastructure definitely does.
I tell you that because what I am not is someone who works in cancer clinical
trials. And so Ellie asked me to come here and look at this from the
outside to take a look at the technologies and the
architecture across the system, which is what I will share with you here.
I have no disclosures.
So Ellie set this problem up quite well, right?
7% of cancer patients enroll in trials.
It's estimated that 8% would need to enroll to fill all the open
trial spots, and yet 50% of trials fail to enroll.
So why is this? This is a systems design problem.
And we can look at this as a two-sided optimization problem, right?
If you're a patient, what do you want?
You're not thinking about trial enrollment, per se, at
all. What you want is access to the very best treatment that's going
to help you, particularly at a time when what you are likely
doing is trying to save your own life.
And so you're wondering, "Is a trial my best
option for access to treatment?"
On the other side, the sponsors are looking at this at what I call a
many-to-one problem, right? So you have a trial,
you are testing a particular therapy, you want to look at it in multiple patients,
and so you're a trial looking for many patients.
In order to find your patients, right, you need to fit into that first
workflow. And so these are related problems, but they are not the
same problem.
Oops, that is the wrong direction.
Okay, so what does this workflow look like for clinical trial
enrollment? And so I've outlined it here
in six basic quadrants. And what I would say is the
first set, which is about study design, patient
identification, and qualification, this is a data
problem, fundamentally. The second half, around routing,
referral, enrollment,
participation, completion, this is a navigation and operations
problem. And I'm going to focus on the data part of this primarily, in part
because that's my expertise, but also in part because this is where I see a
lot of the investment, particularly the private investment, is focused.
And so we'll start with... Oh, I'm doing it again.
I'm going to stop using the mouse.
I'm going to start with what I see on the public side.
What does public investment look like in clinical trial infrastructure?
Well, when we think about study design, the development
of
digital twins, the evaluation of biomarkers and enrollment criteria,
right? We have a good and growing set of data and knowledge bases, many of
which are founded in
public databases.
I think one of the most important things that we've seen coming out of the public
domain is in fact the clinical trial registries, such as
clinicaltrials.gov, that allows us to actually see all of the
trials that do exist. These are imperfect in that they don't
capture truly all of the
inclusion/exclusion criteria one might need in order
to truly qualify a patient, but they do give us a representation of what
exists.
The other, I think, absolutely essential public
contribution here is in access to
patient data through TEFCA. So it used to be that you could
only access data through the
institution itself for which a patient resided,
and now there are interoperability requirements and
standards that are maturing and growing the field for which
data can truly be liquid and flow between
institutions or to other entities.
There's relatively little, I'd say, public investment, at least from
my perspective, into the navigation and patient support side,
although I will note that there have been
semi-recent
updates to CMS reimbursement that do now reimburse for navigation, which is at
least supportive and helpful. On the
other side, we have private investment, and here I've written there's more than $2
billion in private investment into this problem.
I will note that I didn't take the time to collate how much public
investment there's been, but indeed, it's
probablyIt's probably equivalent.
On the private side, again, we see folks really interested on the data side of the
problem, and this is quite simply because a lot of this money is coming
from VC, and VC just has a certain
requirement in terms of the scale and timeline to
return that looks a lot like investing in tech problems
rather than in service-based problems, such as what you would find on the
navigation side.
The advent of AI and the emerging algorithms
that we've all been experiencing over the last several
years has been very supportive here.
In particular, when we think about data extraction and the matching
problem, we see a lot of progress here.
So there's three sets of data that I think are really important to this
problem. One, of course, is the patient's data itself.
Do we have access to the full medical record?
Do we have access to the imaging? Do we have access to the
genomics? And do we understand the full
longitudinal
context for that patient?
And as I say, that is becoming an easier problem
to solve, both through policy and
through the technologies that have arose.
The second piece is the trial data itself.
As I noted, clinicaltrials.gov gives us the ability
to pre-screen patients, but not truly the ability
to fully match them. And so that actually tends to
come through relationships,
relationships that an institution or one of these companies have
with the sponsors. And so there is a limitation there that's outside
of the domain of technology.
And the third is the data and the knowledge bases that are used
for
patient matching for developing digital twins to get a sense of
which of these
many trials is truly the best option
for a patient, and in fact, more than just the best option, a good option.
It's worthwhile for the patient to enroll.
We also see a lot of work going on in this second category of site
optimization and network expansion.
This is really focused on the operational side of clinical
trial running to make this as efficient and streamlined as
possible. And as we saw
through Ellie's comments, there's a long way to go here.
And then, of course, the third is navigation and patient support.
Okay. So when I look at these solutions, I see that access to trial
is really limited by the model that the solution is taking.
We see solutions that take a within hospital system approach, so they
integrate into hospital systems, or they initiate from
within a hospital system. And within a situation like
this,
the program really is meant to serve clinicians and
patients at that institution. But what it can do primarily is
match a patient to the trials that are available at that
institution. And again, this has to do with access and availability,
or sorry, access to trial protocols.
In contrast, we see groups that are starting to build systems outside of the
hospital that may integrate across multiple hospital systems.
And in this case, we see that these are often paid for and
serve the pharma sponsors and sometimes the hospital systems
themselves, usually a combination of those two.
In this case, access to trials for matching often
comes from either direct or indirect sponsor relationships.
And I think the point I'm trying to make here is that
any patient who is in our system is going to have
access
to match with some of the trials that exist, but not
all of the trials, regardless of whether this is coming from within your
medical system or across one of these partnering
companies. And in fact, some patients will have access to
more or less than others.
Okay, so I want to end with a couple of thoughts.
One is that although tech is able to greatly help
support and advance the work that's going on here, there are
structural problems here, as in many places in research and
medicine, that are simply not solved by better tech.
So one is this problem I just talked about of partial
visibility. Each of these solutions exposes
each patient to some trials and each trial to some patients, but
we don't have a many-to-many opportunity here.
The second is that the buyer determines optimization.
So who is paying for this service? It may
be the pharma sponsor, it may be the hospital system, but it is
actually rarely the patient. And unless the patient is
paying, there's no guarantee that the system is being
optimized for the patient's needs.
Now, I don't mean this to be suggesting that there's anything
nefarious going on, and certainly the patient's needs is
considered in the solution that is built, but it is just the case
that the needs of the buyer are going to
influence the solution. And then the third point I wanted to make
was one of consolidation. There's been a lot of investment
in many different technologies and many different companies
over the last couple of years in this space.
And what we see in any
area when that happens is ultimately
consolidation. You see a lot of people come in and build a technology
that solves one point on this
workflowAnd then in order to truly find
efficiencies, they need to integrate with others who are building other
point solutions to other pieces of this.
And you start to get vertical integration, and we are starting to really see that
in this field, a series of companies that are
starting to provide full stack
solutions across all of this. And this is a great
opportunity for efficiency and actually
builds amazing data sets that could be used to integrate
back into supporting patients. But it does mean that they hold
greater sway over the system at large.
And finally, in terms of where do I think technology is
going next here? I talked to many people, and what I heard
time and time again is that where we need to be focused is study
design. So trial enrollment has to align with the
patient's care needs. If it doesn't, the patient is
not going to enroll. And so there are ways to better
design studies to meet a patient's need, and
alleviate burden. We are seeing interesting methodologies
advancing that help support the design of
trials that take shorter times or fewer patients to get to an answer,
which is helpful in this problem. And again, there's this interesting
phenomenon going on that the data resources to support all of this
are really shifting from the public to the private sector.
I'll end there. Thank you.
That was fantastic. Thank you so much. Our next speaker is Dr.
Debra Schrag.
Good afternoon, and thank you for being here.
I'm mindful that I am standing between you
and a drink towards the end of a meeting.
Okay. Well,
Lara and I didn't coordinate. I'm a medical oncologist,
and
I'm also a department chair, which means I spend a lot of time taking care of
medical oncologists who are PIs of clinical trials, take
care of patients, and
they want to recruit to clinical trials.
And, I work in an organization, MSK, that is really
prioritized and focused on clinical trials.
We may be a little over 7%
in terms of, but we have this problem, as does every
major organization. My only disclosure, I have no relevant disclosures
other than that I am involved in making decisions about which of these private
firms
we will be adopting, and we're looking at a lot of them and working in a lot of
them, but I've tried to make my remarks free of any specific
commercial.
So I think of this as a voltage drop, and it
really is what Lara said, just maybe put on the vertical, not
the horizontal.
When we sort of divide all those 50 tasks in
that micro-font,
the first thing we have to figure out is: Is there a trial available?
Are there trial options? Are we in a trial desert?
There are certainly parts of the country and cancers for which there's a
desert. There's no option. And that could be geographic based, or
it could be that HIV is an exclusion criteria, there are no trials for
individuals with HIV or all kinds of
reasons. Then there's eligibility criteria, and we know how
long and convoluted and complicated those can get and how much time is
spent trying to get that information out of EHRs.
Then there's the engagement piece.
And engagement is both clinicians
and patients trying to engage them in clinical trials, why a clinical
trial may be a good option, what it means, addressing all the
issues, and ultimately enrolling and doing,
finally, the enablement that is necessary for an individual to
stay on a clinical trial through completion and to participate
in valid assessment of the endpoints.
So really what's happening right now, amidst all of the enthusiasm for
AI, there's really a frenzy in public and private
sectors and internal to academic
medical centers.
How can we harness the power of AI to prevent
this voltage drop and help us accelerate accrual to
clinical trials? And what strategies can we use to help
support participation?
So primarily, and this is really the data problem that
Lara was talking about, not the operations, most of the
AI firms are focused on the second step,
AI-supported trial availability matching and
eligibility, what I call provisional screening.
They can't do complete screening because screening is dynamic.
No matter how much you screen and how great your algorithm is and how
well your AI picks up structured and unstructured data,
it cannot figure out... Well, sorry.
Maybe it can figure out if an individual is pregnant, but it doesn't do a
pregnancy test on the day that you enroll in the trial.
So it can do some kind of provisional screening, but it can't make sure that the
patient is not pregnant the day they start the
study. So we just have tremendous, within the last
even 12 months, interest, new companies, companies
getting bigger, lots of capital flowing into this space because it is
so tedious and so many humans have worked for so long to
do clinical trial matching, and there's a lot of focus
in that space. Not necessarily always an end-to-end
solution going all the way from availability to
enablement.I think as we think about solving
this problem,
considering the vantage point is critical.
Who's the user? What's the need? And how does one
person's use of AI influence others?
So as a clinician, I have had patients come with
Claude, with ChatGPT, with Gemini, each
with a different recommendation.
We saw this from the internet, and now it's just the same thing all over again.
I'm old enough so that I've seen this movie before.
It is overwhelming. So someone's use of AI
is someone else's new workflow, and I
think that's key.
This is really another way of saying what Lara said, but matching
trials to patients, which is what PIs,
and that PI could be an academic investigator who's hot to trot with
their investigator-initiated new trial, and it could also be a company,
is not the same as what doctors do, which is matching
patients to trials. Drug developers, PIs,
and innovators, my trial needs patients. Where are they?
Where can I find them? Clinician, my patient needs a trial.
Which ones are available and appropriate?
And clinicians want the best for their patients.
They don't care, my health system, your health system.
It could be in Argentina, it could be in Japan, anywhere.
They want the best for their patients.
Health systems, their perspective is the clinicians and patients in our
system need help finding trials and accruing to them
efficiently. It can't slow them down so much that they only see two
patients a day. And of course, patients and families for whom this is
ultimately about are, "I need to find the best
trial for me." So these are
interrelated but non-identical challenges.
So looking at the blue boxes across the top, when you break down
each of these steps, the patients need to know what trials are
accessible to me because I can't drive eight hours.
Two hours I can do, eight I can't. Do I qualify?
What are the risks and benefits? Should I participate, and how can I participate
and keep working, keep my paycheck, et cetera?
What doctors want to know in the red boxes are what trials are best for my patient?
Is my patient eligible without it completely slowing down
my clinical workflow?
How do I best educate my patient about this trial?
What tools and resources do I need to educate them?
How can I coordinate informed and efficient enrollment?
And then how do I support them as they're on
this journey?
So I would say AI is what everyone's excited about right now, but there are a
lot of strategies beyond AI that have incredible promise.
So trial design, I think as Lara mentioned,
decentralization of clinical trials and simplification are
critical. We have met the enemy, and it is often us,
clinicians, who write protocols.
We have to keep them simple. If a protocol
includes ordinary chemotherapy, it should be able to be
administered anywhere. If people need a restaging CT
scan, you should not have to drive two hours back to my center to have a CAT
scan done on our machine. We need to use
telehealth, flexible timing windows.
Informed consent visits ought to be able to be done
by telehealth, video-informed consents.
Instead of every clinician doing the informed consent, we ought to have
video-informed consents be included as part of IRB submission
packages, so our best communicators.
Our patients look at TikTok and
Instagram. We should have TikTok and Instagram
informed consent.
At this meeting, the RevMed drug for pancreas cancer,
the data was presented, but Ben Sasse,
the former senator from Nebraska, was on the drug and did a feature in "The New
York Times," and his face was all over "The New York Times."
People looked at the rash. There's the informed consent.
A picture is often better than a 30-page single-spaced
consent form. So, I think video-informed consents
with real patients and really skilled, experienced
physicians would go a long way to supporting
accrual. And then monitoring needs to be home-based so
people aren't coming in for lots of tox checks which could be
avoided or done by phone, tracking, monitoring, home phlebotomy.
We need to make it easier, and this, I guess, is part of the
operations piece. Okay, so where are we today?
So I can poke fun at my own institution.
This is real. The patient is blocked out.
This is not exactly AI, but this is leveraging a knowledge base.
So my institution does genomic profiling routinely,
and we profile patients, and then we nudge doctors.
So I call this first-generation clinical trial matching.
It's delivery of a clinical nudge based on institutional genomic
data and an in-house trial portfolio.
This is a true example. You can see I received this email last week,
04/16/2026,
and it says, "The MSK Cohort Management System for Clinical Trial Matching has
identified the following patient," name blacked out, "as potentially eligible
for one or more studies, pending additional review."
And it's just sent to me in my daily digest
email to stop and worry about. Here's the second
page when you go into the email.
Here's a protocol, Phase 1/2 trial of mirvetinib in
patients with MAP kinase mutant CNS tumors.
Lung adenocarcinoma is what my patient had.
Those of you who know me know that I treat GI
cancer.Okay. So this patient has a
visit on 4/22. I think that might be tomorrow.
She's coming in, so I got the prompt, and you can see the
eligibility. The best thing about this email is the button at the bottom.
Click here to email the study team.
Okay, that's good.
But I laughed when I saw this because I treated this patient
in 2004, and she happened to have sent me a
message on February 3rd. She thought I worked at a different
institution where Ellie works and said, "I celebrated with
a big, noisy party on my 80th birthday, considering I had stage
four colorectal cancer when you came into my life in 2004.
Some good news and a big thank you." So I know that this
patient matched with her MAPK for her secondary lung cancer, not what I
treated her. So wrong doctor, wrong patient, makes no sense.
But this patient trusts me, and if I tell her to go on a clinical trial, she
will. Just illustrating that we have this process.
We nudge doctors all the time, but just like clinical decision support
is often-- Any physicians in the room?
When you get clinical decision support, often you're like, "Next."
Have an end-of-life discussion. Do this.
We've seen this movie before. It's clinical decision support all over again.
So we have to implement these tools, right study, right patient, right time,
and the right prompt.
Lots of companies are trying to do this.
AI is trying to help industry sponsors quickly find potential participants
matching a trial to patients. But we, as clinicians, it doesn't
work for us to have 50 companies each representing
10 trials. It's quickly chaos, and it's clinical decision support.
News we cannot use. So I don't think it will
ultimately be all that successful without
integration.
So this is a little more advanced. This is a second-generation
clinical nudge. And this is a study I really
like that was led by Tali Mazor and Ken Kiel
at Dana-Farber, where they said, "We're going to fix
the timing problem by looking at restaging scans, and we're going to
deliver the nudge, not at random times like the one I just showed you,
but at salient time points when there's clinical progression on a CT
scan." So they interrogated a very similar genomic database,
but they delivered the nudge at the salient
moment of progression. They randomized two to one,
to
have physicians get a nudge or not get a nudge to see if it
would increase clinical trial accrual.
Unfortunately, it did not. So it
didn't work. They got the technology integrated. It all worked.
It wasn't that. But it is hard to move the needle.
When you dig deep and into it, I think the study is not
completely negative. There is a couple of percentage point
advantage shown by the lighter green bars on the right compared to the control
darker green bars. If a patient was starting a new
therapy or regimen, those if they were
in the intervention group and their physician had received a clinical trial nudge,
were more likely to be accrued, but it was only a couple.
But I think this is just
the beginning and a first step, and I think that
we will get there. So what are third-generation clinical
nudges going to look like to support matching?
We're going to have AI screens for potential protocol matches and
eligibility pre-screen. It's not going to get us all the way there, but it's going
to get us really, I think, quite far.
Never the pregnancy test, never those things that need to be done on day of
enrollment, but we will be able to do a lot.
The pre-screen are going to extract structured and unstructured data from
the EHR. We already know this can work.
They're going to need to include data that spans multiple systems
because of how fragmented patients' care are.
Our patients go all over, not just one site.
They're going to have to be linked to salient events and time points, not just
scattershot. They're going to have to be delivery platforms
beyond email nudges, ideally integrated into the
electronic health record or seamlessly sitting on
top of the EHR.
And even better, if there's a potential match and you
deliver me a potential match, give me the option right then and there to say,
"Would you like to send your patient a video consent so they can learn more
about the trial? Click here. Would you like a nurse to call and schedule a
screening telehealth visit? Click here." So again, we have to
integrate the matching with the next steps.
I think that will come. The underlying
method that are used for these matching algorithms, and this is a data
science piece, is going to influence the yield of these matching algorithms.
And we do have to pay attention to make sure we don't leave people out.
Because if the matching algorithm is bad, there's a simple counting, a
tiering, weighting, tiering. There are different methods, and depending on the
method, we could leave some people behind, and we're going to have to
pay attention.
If we have fewer matching criteria, like if we just match on age, site,
histology, stage, and biomarker expression.
So for example, find a trial for an adult with BRAF mutant metastatic
colorectal cancer.
We're going to have more options, but that means more sifting for the
clinical team, which still has a considerable workload.
Whereas if we have more matching criteria, we're going to have fewer
options for docs to sift through.
We could still have salient timing, but we may miss options by
including too many dynamic elements.
So for example, if we exclude people with ECOG 2 who were just
hospitalized for pneumonia, we may inappropriately screen
people out.
All right, I have a question, just see who's awake.
What is the biggest barrier to clinical trials accrual from
patients' perspective?Any thoughts?
Anybody just want to shout anything out? What's the biggest barrier?
This is from survey data.
Travel.
What?
Travel comes up a lot, but I don't think it's the biggest.
In other words, that, whatever, in what Ellie showed, 7%.
What's keeping the other 93%?
Time commitment.
Time is one.
So I'm not going to torture you at the end of the day.
Number one is actually trust.
And
even though doctors, we are a trusted profession,
it's an uphill struggle. People trust and click yes, yes, yes,
accept Google can track me and know where I am, and we click yes on the phone
without reading what we're saying yes to.
But when it comes to clinical trials and how you're going to treat me, there is a
lot of mistrust, and that comes out ahead of logistics, and
logistics is the travel, the cost, and
everything else.
I think everyone knows that erosion of trust in physicians is
increasing. We still look good compared to lawyers, members
of Congress, car salesmen, lobbyists.
You can see we're still up at the top, but we're not as good as we
used to be. This is according to the most recent Gallup poll, and we've
actually had a significant
drop, and we don't need to talk about politics at the very end of the day.
But who do patients trust? They still trust us, but they
really trust nurses, and I think we ignore that at our
peril. We look pretty similar to pharmacists.
We're still ahead of police. You can see that we did really well at the height of
the pandemic. We had a little surge in the Gallup poll, but
we've fallen off since then.
There's something that I think about a lot called the engagement trust matrix,
and when we design an accrual strategy, we have to think about where a
patient is and where they fall in this matrix.
Patients in the top two boxes, these are high-trust patients.
The top box on the right, these folks seek trials independently, and they're likely
to accept your recommendation. The patients in the top left box
are pretty low in awareness. They probably haven't been searching, but they're
likely to accept results of matching if you can
explain it reasonably well.
The folks on the right are tough because they're low trust and high
engagement, and they're the ones who've done all the work and have 10
relatives who've searched for them, and they take a lot of time and enroll in
trials at 10 different sites, and they're a
lot. But the vast majority of patients fall into the
cell on the lower left. They're unlikely to seek trials, they have
low awareness and/or interest, and they are hesitant about
uncertainty or risks, and an AI model is
not going to overcome that.
What's the biggest barrier to clinician engagement in clinical trial accrual?
Any thoughts?
Time.
What?
Yes, time. Absolutely. Time is number one.
What is the biggest barrier to health system engagement in clinical trial
accrual?
Money.
Yay, Sean's perfect.
Money is number one and integration is number two.
So all you companies who are just doing one little piece of the
thank you for the clinical trial matching, thank you for the nudge,
but now how do we go move to the next step?
Simple things we could do today. I'm working on them, trying to
get us to do them in my health system, but boy, change is hard.
Relying on telehealth for clinical trials, education, screening, and consent,
making video-informed consents the norm, providing transportation
vouchers for participants, decentralize so that we
scan anywhere, blood draw anywhere, and standard of treatment anywhere,
even if it's not in our system, and digital monitoring and self-reporting
for most toxicity evaluations.
So I'm optimistic about AI. I think the future
will be collegial. It will be artificial intelligence plus
human intelligence plus better system design, and that that's how we'll
accelerate recruitment and expand clinical trial participation.
AI adoption is going to be fast in the eligibility matching space,
but it really has applications across the continuum.
When it comes to patient engagement, that's where we need
human intelligence, human time, and effort to build
trust, and I'm hopeful that the AI tools will free
docs up to be able to do that. And then health system
design is necessary to undergird this entire
enterprise. So just to conclude, my
predictions are that the use of AI to expand clinical trials accruals is
going to take off like wildfire over the next five years.
AI will be the primary approach to finding patients appropriate clinical trials
options.
Health systems that invest in AI implementation and
integration across each of those five buckets will realize the greatest
accrual gains. And health systems that invest in both AI
integration and infrastructure that supports patient and clinician
engagement and really attend to that trust piece will also be the
ones that realize the biggest gains in accrual.
AI is going to partner and not replace us, so we are all good
for
job security.
Thank you.
That was fantastic. So now invite Deb and Laura to come back onto the stage.
So
as promised,
one of the other wonderful parts about this session is that it's intentionally
designed with a robust amount of Q&A opportunities.
And
you have a
once in a lifetime opportunity to query two world
leaders in this space about a really hard problem.
And so certainly invite people to come to the microphone. Don't be shy.
And
would love to have your questions, and likewise for folks online.
While we're waiting for some brave souls,
I can kickstart.
And I guess each of you talked about, in different ways,
the explosion of small companies each trying to
solve this problem, and thenSome case alluded to
at least one epically large company
seeming like it wanted to solve its problem,
and the sort of disappearance of the public
sector in what could have been its role.
What do you think are the risks of each of these kinds of...
The millions of small companies or the one big company, and
what are we going to do about it?
So I don't think there's too much to do about it in
terms of the small versus large companies, because this is just the way
technology gets adopted across most fields, right?
You start with individual point solutions.
You figure out actually you can't
make your necessary revenue numbers that way, they plateau, and then you
consolidate. You go out of business or you merge, right?
And so I think that's the way of
the world. I think what's really interesting is
this
new development of these bigger companies that are increasingly
having access to as many or as more patients and
their data as you see within the individual cancer care
institutions or bigger centers. And,
I'm
curious to see how that plays out in terms of
how the data is used to improve
care, but also to innovate in clinical trial designs.
I don't have a
prediction as to exactly
whether that's going to be better or worse, but I think it's going to mean there's
a different set of people looking at the problem.
So,
my thoughts are that actually for right now, we have to sit and live with
the messiness a little bit. Because the technology's new,
and if somebody comes with a grand idea and says,
"I integrate across the entire space,"
that's a great ambition, but prove to us that you can actually do it.
Let's not just go adopt you. Because it may be that there are 10 little
companies, and one little company has a great algorithm for our
melanoma patients. And another company has a great
algorithm for our leukemia patients.
And we need to be able to try those, see how they
work, what the good features are, and we need to learn from each of those efforts.
So if a company is going to do clinical trial matching for leukemia and
lymphoma, or
frankly even just T-cell lymphoma, rock on.
Go for it. Let's work with you. Let's try.
Because whatever we learn about your clinical trial matching in T-cell lymphoma,
it may not work for breast cancer, and that's okay.
We need some experience
getting our paws on different models so that we can learn about the best
features and what works. It's no different than biomarker development
assays, right? When we're screening to find
biomarkers, genomic markers, the best assay for what you treat,
Ellie, prostate cancer, may not be the best for what I treat,
which is colorectal cancer. And that's okay. Maybe we need a market basket.
So I think we're in this messy space where we've got a lot of
little efforts, and we will get consolidation and
integration, but right now we're just in this peak
innovation, and we have to figure out how to test and
evaluate nimbly with rapid cycle.
And then some of those companies will fall by the wayside, and some of them will
merge with each other. We may end up with a market basket
of solutions. But I want to say one thing about the public
option, which is,
I think you mentioned that when you go to clinicaltrials.gov, you can't do a
great job on matching because there's limited structured data.
I think that if you're going to design a protocol and you want to get patients from
all over the country or all over the world, you should have to
put your eligibility and exclusion criteria in
structured format completely.
And so if clinicaltrials.gov included
your creatinine needs to be less than 1.5 on a Tuesday
afternoon. You need a pregnancy test that's negative within three days
of starting drug. If all that were actually in the
databases, everybody could design better algorithms a
lot more quickly that would save clinicians time and let us focus
on
the human intelligent part that we are really stuck at.
Fantastic. Thank you.
Does that answer your question?
That's wonderful. Thank you. We have questions at the microphone.
I don't know who was first.
Okay.
Yeah, so we'll go right to the-- Yeah, go ahead.
Yeah, great. Thank you. Wonderful talk. Andy McKenzie.
I lead the personalized medicine efforts at the Sarah Cannon Research Institute
based in Nashville, Tennessee.
So we've been intimately connected with patient matching and all this stuff for
a decade now, and I guess that's part of my question is,
it's not a new concept to do patient matching.
We're aiming different technologies at it and trying to be a little bit more
sophisticated. We're supporting a network of community-based
medical oncology practices across the country, so not just any one hospital
or hospital system.
And I'm just wondering your thoughts on,
is a new widget the answer, or should we try to dig deeper
into the actual incentives about medicine
in America today? That clinical research maybe doesn't match up with
clinical care in the incentive space, and maybe that's why we haven't seen
that 7% number move over the past, I don't know,
decade or two. So I just wonder your thoughts on that.
Andrea?
Go ahead.
So I agree with you. AI is like a new cool toy
technology, but we can just build clinical decision support based
on
... existing data that could sit in something like an Excel spreadsheet
or a file of genomic data. In some sense, you could say it's not
really a new challenge.
When it comes to incentives, I think we have to
be really careful. And I think we have to be really careful because of what I said
about trust.
Trust is critical.
So I'll give you two examples, and one is a personal example.
So what if we paid doctors more
if they had higher accrual? Just
creating new knowledge is a value,
and if we just said, "You're going to get a bonus at the end of the year based on
whether you had
less than 10, 10 to 20, or more than 20% of your patients enrolled in a
clinical trial." And we just paid doctors that way.
In some sense, I think the concept of informed consent and
free will, and there's a coercive, ethical, sort of
treacherous, somewhat slippery slope.
So as a faculty leader of oncologists,
I look at all the oncologists in my
group, and that's a lot, and I look at who's put
patients on clinical trials and who hasn't, and I have an
integer next to each one
and debate with all the other faculty leaders whether that's a performance
evaluation factor that we can use for
informing, I guess, whether your annual raise is going up this much
or this much. It's pretty small.
And we've decided not to do that.
Do we look, do we know? We're like the people who put a lot of patients on trials,
get a lot of referrals, a lot of papers, a lot of glory, but that ethically it's a
little bit
treacherous and we really want to not be coercive when it
comes to patients, and that we really have some moral and
ethical obligations to patients.
I think that's also what we've heard from our patients.
They really want to feel that when they're seeing a physician, we're not
incentivized to put them on a study, that we are incentivized to
make the best possible recommendation for them, that we can
trial
or not trial at our site, or sending them
to Sarah Cannon.
So
I think it's ethically treacherous, I guess, would be the answer.
Hear, hear.
I guess in terms of the widget piece, I would say yes.
I started my career in what was bioinformatics, and then it
was data science, and now it's AI, right?
We are evolving, but these are all
different sides of the same coin.
What I have seen that I think has been very interesting in the last couple
of years is the ability to start to
gather, curate, and harmonize data across hospital systems.
So in your community
hospital example, I do think that there's better
capabilities now to support you in providing support
across a distributed network like that.
And I think that's a huge win because that limits whatever algorithm
you're trying to use.
And I just want to also say kudos to you and Sarah Cannon because you're
way higher than 7%.
So first of all,
thank you. This was really interesting.
And you kind of touched on this in your recent edit, Terry.
Can you-
Can you speak up?
Yeah, hold the microphone closer. Thanks.
Can you hear me now?
Yeah.
Yes.
Thank you. This was really interesting and informative, and you kind of touched on
this in the previous
response, but
what do you think is the anecdote to building a greater trust
in physicians and in healthcare and also in research, in
science in general? Aside from, I know
in addition, in the larger scheme of things, why is it that the
nurses have such a higher
trust
rate in comparison to others? Why is it declining?
I know that in general, it's something that's kind of been addressed.
And Francis Collins speaks about this in his most recent book with
regards to COVID. He speaks about how he feels like he could've done a better done
at communication. Do you think that there's a need more for
physicians to be on TikTok and social media and be sharing,
to be communicating to the public in general?
Or
what is it that's really the best anecdote to try and reverse this
decline of trust?
I'm happy to take that one. I'm curious what Ellie would say about it.
I think
that the healthcare system has failed people.
I actually don't think that more doctors on
TikTok and Instagram and social media is
the answer.
People look at that, they like that. They're influencers.
We all know that they're influencers.
There's Kim Kardashian, and there is the doctor version of Kim
Kardashian. But when it's my health and my cancer and I'm
sick, or my kids are sick,
I want a doctor who is in the room, who knows me,
who's focused on me.
So I'm a physician,
and
it is very hard for me to get primary care for my family
members. Very hard. Okay. I have kids in their
20s. It is hard. The American healthcare system has failed
many people, and people feel that their care is
fragmented and siloed, and nobody knows them, and that they have to
be the master and commander and the coordinator of
their own ship. And the trust is low, and that's
educated, uneducated,
it takes all forms. So I think
that when people have longitudinal healing relationships and they know there
is a physician who has their back and who will sit
with them and help them figure out, given your needs and that your daughter's
getting married in two weeks and your kid is
graduating and-... your wishes, and given that I know you, we're going to make
a good decision that for you to fly to San Diego for a clinical trial,
not right now." That's what people want.
They want a physician who they know they can trust, who knows
them,
and will help them arrive at a good decision.
People crave that, and I don't think we're going to fix that
with social media. But I do think that unburdening
physicians with some of the tedious tasks in,
I think in your list of all those 50 things, and little...
That that will help. And that is what physicians also want, actually.
I think there's some secondary strategies that help.
Patients are influenced by other patients, patients like me.
That goes a long way. But I think
we're having a moment in pancreas cancer right now because
of what's happened at this meeting and because of the senator from Nebraska, and we
have a surge of hundreds of phone calls at
my organization, at
Ellie's too. The phones are ringing off the hook because patients have seen
testimonials from other patients.
But even though they have, they want to hear from a doctor they know and trust.
That's what they want.
Ellie, would you disagree?
Yeah. I'm not going to chime in, Baldo, do you want to?
No, go for it. Yeah.
Nope. So it's a great question. I think Deb's points are spot on.
It's really a hard problem. I think
our community has ceded a lot of the ground by not
engaging, and I think some of that, and to bring it back to this
session, actually, is specifically not engaging in the use
of technology ourselves.
It is because so much of this novel tech is directly in patients'
hands. I'm specifically thinking at this point about agentic
AI approaches, language models, ChatGPT.
People are just using it, and they're using it to search for trials.
They're using it to punch their symptoms in.
And one surefire way to not help
oneself is if they present it to the providers, and the providers are immediately
dismissive of this new technology that they are hearing about and
using in other forms of their life.
That feeds into this sense of,
"They've been holding this back from me this whole time.
And I don't trust them anymore. I'm losing my trust in this entity because they're
holding things back from me." And so one very practical thing we can do as a
community is make sure we are educated and at the forefront
of understanding and learning the same kinds of technologies that are in the hands
of the patients. The other thing that I'd mention, and just in the
context of this session, that actually you alluded to, that I would just
expand upon is
some of the... In the title, it was intentionally vague and broad
on purpose, but novel technologies and AI could
mean things like AI scribes. And so why are we bringing up AI
scribes? Because the introduction of the AI
scribes, and I know that there's been some mixed results in the
quantitative literature in certain clinical settings.
But at least, and I know I'm not supposed to use anecdotal work, but it was so
dramatic, it's hard not to
see this, is that the
binary before and after introduction of the AI scribes into the
clinic immediately freed the providers from doing what
we sometimes have to do, so we're not charting at 3:00 in the morning.
So instead of typing my notes, I'm back to doing the human
part of being a doctor, making eye contact, being human,
engaging in that bond,
and that increases trust. And then that could lead
to more trust in when I say, "There's this trial you might want to think about,"
and so on and so forth. And so the novel technology is almost like a
secondary part of it, but it helps the
provider
be more equipped to build up the thing they need to do
to build the trust back up.
The last thing I'll say is that some of this is really not something
we can control. It's hard not to acknowledge that the
technology is being harnessed for massive misinformation campaigns,
very directed and some cases, some could argue,
politically motivated
shifts and intentional shifts in
what should or should not be studied in cancer or
research, let's say, or clinical trials.
And again, that combined with people who have access to that
information at their fingertips, while we're just saying...
If we're just dismissing it and saying, "Oh, that's nuts. That's crazy.
You're not going to give ivermectin to this metastatic pancreas cancer patient."
You almost have to hear them out and listen so that you can then
robustly, but thoughtfully engage and then
dissuade if it's worth dissuading,
but meet them where they're at. So again, and how do you do that?
Well, if you're not sitting there typing in the chart and instead you're making
eye contact and talking to them one-on-one, you have more time and freedom to do
those kinds of things. So there's certainly more. It's a really hard one.
And this is probably just bits and pieces of it, but you hit the nail on the head
in terms of what some of the biggest problems are.
Laurie, did you have anything to add or next? Oh, no.
No, I don't work in the profession the way you two do, so I will
defer to you two for this question.
Two questions over there. Right. We have two folks over there. Great. Thank you.
Go ahead.
Yeah. Thank you for the talk. Really wonderful.
One question I have about trust, which seems to be
a common theme, is do you see the, I guess, degradation of trust
go down in certain,
I guess, rural versus urban versus young versus
old, in different types of populations?
Or is it just everyone all at once?
In your experience, either statistical or anecdotal,
what have you seen that-
In your patient populations, I think, to repeat the question?
Yeah. Can you hear me?
Yes.No, the lights are so bright.
This is Noah.
Yeah. Hey, how's it going? Good. Sorry.
I'm in and out of.
I can't see anyone in there.
It's hard. Yeah, we can't see.
So I think your question was,
please correct me if I'm wrong, but just try to rephrase it.
You had mentioned that there's just a global decline in trust.
We were just talking about trust.
Mm-hmm.
You're asking, is that decline universal, or are there
certain segments of the population for which the decline is
more severe or less severe? So is it young or old people?
Is it people from certain geographic regions, certain socioeconomic backgrounds?
Was that the question?
Yeah.
So, let me say that
the data that I showed you is from the Gallup
Poll news organization, and it's all US population.
It's not patients, it's not hospitals.
So let me just qualify it that it's
population-wide. But yes, when you slice it, the erosion in
physician trust spans
age categories, gender,
race, ethnicity. If you dig in, and you can go to the Gallup website
and play around. One thing that struck me when I was poking around in there is that
actually men are more trusting
of physicians than women, which is men seek
medical care less, but they are more trusting than women by
quite four or five percentage points.
So there's some gender difference, and I think that
spans all
ages. And again, it's all physicians.
It's not oncologists or trialists or
researchers. But we do have a very fragmented
healthcare system where people see an APP or they go to a
pharmacist, or they may have a PCP,
but when they're hospitalized and acutely ill, their PCP doesn't come see them
anymore. So
there's more pressure that
you have to be in charge, and we hear from caregivers,
particularly cancer caregivers, all the time, "I have to coordinate
everything for my significant other because I'm the
only one who knows the whole story." We hear
that every patient advocacy organization has
stories and examples
of that. So yeah. And, I think obviously
there's some historically, there are communities that have
been left behind or victimized for one reason or another, whether it's based on
color, race, ethnicity, Native American, African American,
et cetera.
But
I would also say that I see a lot of low trust in
extremely well-educated individuals that
results in a lot of entropy and suffering, like
sometimes we see people who've been to five different cancer
centers to try to get enrolled in a trial, and they're
listed five different places, and then we all get on the phone and we're like, "Oh
my goodness."
So
trust deficits
cross
all demographics.
And it's also, I think technology may not help us,
in some sense. If anything, it may exacerbate trust issues.
If there's certain populations who, if they don't have access to the technology,
and then they're feeling left out and/or let's say the AI models that
are built don't work for them or start to spit out nonsense that doesn't apply to
them, that's going to further the problems with trust.
And then likewise, for the folks who are of high resource, actually, if it's
similar, we all, in some cases, it's all the same patients who start at
Sarah Cannon. They go
all the way up, the Northeast. Eventually, they've seen everyone, and we all
realize it's the same person. And then they get mad if they hear
an ever so slightly different variation of what is largely the same thing,
and have a different kind of trust problems when it comes to these trials too.
And it can be even worse because it's somebody who runs a
company who's very entitled, and they've been to Sarah Cannon
and Georgetown in Virginia and Penn and Hopkins,
and now they're coming up the coast to see us.
But they are taking a visit of
somebody who is less privileged and less advantaged, who now
has to wait longer, and the longer people wait, that also erodes
trust. So,
our healthcare system has some structural problems that contribute
to trust erosion, and we need technology, but we have to solve that, too.
I do think that there's
a growing evolution in how folks expect to
engage with their docs, and in particular, I think maybe more in preventative
care. The folks are expecting that they'll use
technology and they won't, for example, ever have a PCP.
And we're continually seeing that.
And so I think
where technology can help, it needs to be integrated
into the medical system, so they're sitting on the same side of the
table, the medical system and the technology that can provide
support.
Thinking about agentic AI. They shouldn't be coming to you and saying, "Hey, I
have
a different technical doctor who's given me this answer." It should be
that you can use a resource like that to help
inform those patients who want to be informed that way, under your
control.
We have a question over there.
Thank you for the talks. I have a couple of a little bit more technical questions.
My first question is regarding patient populations that we may not
necessarily capture using some of these algorithms, and
more related to the idea of completeness.
So one of the issues with the MRs, with any large database, is
completeness of different values that we require to make a decision.
If, let's say, you have 10 different inclusion and exclusion criteria and a
patient only has information for, let's say, half of those, how do we deal with
those patients? Do they go into a separate triage category where we attempt to
find that information, or what happens to that population?
And then my second question is about getting these kind of bumps or
these hints to physicians to the right person. And I think Dr.
Shah pretty or very well showcased that in her presentation.
But if these bumps are going to their primary care physician or the
hospitalist that was in charge of their last admission, that's not very helpful.
How do we make sure that these notifications are going to the right physicians?
So,
the data missingness problem has been a real issue,
and particularly,
I can speak to it from those groups that are outside of an institution
who are looking to use
APIs to gather data across multiple centers
for an individual. You don't necessarily know if when you have missing
data, it's because
that data exists, you just didn't get it in your
pull, or that actually that data was never
pulled at all. And there are increasingly
strategies and methodologies to try to infer
that, and
I would say that I heard mixed feedback on those.
Some of them say they work pretty well, some of them say they don't, but there are
whole companies that are focused on this problem right now.
So,
the solutions are evolving.
And the other part about the nudges, I will defer to you for the nudges.
Yeah.
Well, I will start by saying that we can't leave those people out-
Right
... if there's missing data. So if one of the eligibility criteria is that
you have no brain metastases,
but somebody's never had a brain scan, or you need to have a
negative brain imaging. We can't leave those people out, because otherwise we're
just going to end up including the privileged and leaving
more sectors of the population behind, which will
widen disparities and deepen trust. So we can't do that.
We're going to have to tackle that.
So I think that there is a science of nudge
architecture, and clinical decision support is just
older technology, but there's, I sorry to use the
term implementation science, but there are data for
how you evaluate new technology and
optimize it so that you're giving effective nudges.
Sometimes effective, clunky, old emailed nudges
actually can work. But
we need to test. I think you can trial those nudges. It's pretty easy to do.
There's a lot of evidence about how to do it and how to do it well.
And at the end of the day, now it's easier than ever to track
who's actually
using it, like who opens stuff.
If you send me a nudge and offer me, okay, if you
click here, we'll send your patient, the clinical trials
nurse will call the patient and set up time for a telehealth visit,
or
you send me the protocol so I can look at it and review it.
Would you like a copy of the protocol so you can review it and consider it for your
patient? And if I never click and never open, then it's
not reaching me. So yeah, I
think we have to evaluate
the effectiveness of nudges exactly the way we evaluate the effectiveness of
clinical decision support. I'm trying to think of a recent example.
We had one for, what's it called? SERS criteria for sepsis.
Do you have that one up in your system?
Anyway,
people come in, and we miss sepsis sometimes, and people can die or end up in the
ICU, and it's terrible. So it's one of our most effective clinical
decision support, and people really use it, and it really saves lives.
We have other clinical decision support that reminds doctors to have end of life
conversations with their patients who are dying, and doctors hate it,
and they ignore it, and they don't use it, and they see it, and they get so mad
that they just delete it. So we have to take it down.
So
you have to evaluate, be data-driven.
I think that's what we have to do.
Sarah, a question.
Again, also, thank you for the excellent presentation and discussion, and
you talked about incentives and ethics.
I want to just take a different spin on this,
is the benefit of the patient in the trial.
And with today's technologies, we have a lot more
information available
when a patient is on trial compared to the normal record.
And
in my role advising several investigators, one of the
challenges that they are bumping in when they want to bring in more digital
health information is, would you
provide the same information if the patient would not be on trial, right?
So, is this now
becoming an incentive, which is an ethical
question. However, I think there's a tremendous
opportunity
to
help the patient to engage, that they also get something back.
And we have, with the technologies that we are just
discussing
now, totally new vehicles to do this.
So I just wanted to know what your thoughts are
on this kind of paradigm.
Is this now if we provide more information in a way
that does not jeopardize the integrity of the trial,
but the patient feels more
informed, has access to more information,
is this an incentive that is allowable, that we could
manage to make it attractive for patients?
Good. So I want to give you an extreme example.
We're doing a trial at my site where
we decided that
women who are undergoing IVF give themselves Lupron at
home. They get a prescription,
they give for infertility. But women with breast cancer have to
come into the clinic to get a Lupron shot.
So we decided that we wouldIt's very crazy with
insurance because it's not reimbursed.
But that we would figure out a way that women with stable breast cancer and men
with prostate cancer could self-administer Lupron at home.
But we needed to make it somehow attractive for them, so we paid
for them to have home phlebotomy. So,
a little van comes up, comes into their front door or their apartment,
takes the blood from them so that they can do it at 7 o'clock at night, not
miss work. It's really patient-friendly.
Patients, can you imagine? They loved it.
They're like, "I don't have to come to clinic just for a stupid blood draw.
I can give it myself." They're like, "This is a game changer." Patients were so
happy. But we only offered this to the trial patients.
Patients went off trial, and they're like, "What?
No more home phlebotomy." Okay. Well, we don't have the money to
pay for it. So we took it away from them.
You wouldn't believe the complaints.
They're like, "Why isn't this available for everybody?" It kind of illustrates
your... They're like, "I'm writing to the hospital president.
Why can't everybody have phlebotomy at home?" We're like, "We don't have the money
for it." So, we learn things.
Those people were brave, and they signed up for a trial, and they did
questionnaires and surveys, and they participated.
They got something out of it that seems to be
good and valuable and resonates, and now we have to try to see if we
can integrate it more in our standard care delivery platform,
which so far we've abysmally failed, and we can't because insurance won't pay
for it. But at least it's something that we can work towards and work on.
But I don't think it's unethical, actually, that we provided
home phlebotomy, and I actually don't think it's unethical that we said, "Trial's
over. You can't have it anymore." It's unfortunate,
it's disappointing, it's frustrating.
I'm sad, but I don't think it's unethical.
I just think it's
unfortunate. That's a specific example.
I don't know if that's...
Yeah, no. This is-
Did I understand your question?
This is fantastic.
Yeah.
Because I strongly agree with what you are saying
because we can now use, especially the digital
technologies also to
help the patient better understand where they are in the care cycle, where they are
in the clinical trial.
And I think
that is of tremendous value to the patient.
Right. Actually, what we really do is we said to the patients, "Why don't you
try to work with the patient advocacy organizations so
that your Aetna health insurance will
cover this service?"
Thank you.
So we're just about done, but I can't help myself.
And I'm just sorry to keep those brave folks still here from
the
evening festivities. But I have one last question for this esteemed panel.
So a lot of what you both talked about in your presentations, what was talked about
in this discussion sounds like it's
breaking down a problem about trial enrollment that includes some
combination of text-based
product,
visual
product like
video consents-
Mm-hmm
... audio product, interactions, and Q&A,
and building trust
in some kind of stepwise fashion.
How far away are we or will we ever get to a
point where you could imagine a scenario where a
agentic platform which
has currently capabilities of both
text-based work,
automated video generation, audio-based back and forth, and
the ability to execute tasks in various stepwise fashions to
varying degrees of success, like we all see with certain coding agents and that
kind of thing.
Is that the future? And if... Is that a
future and is that a future we want?
Or is that just crazy?
I don't think that's crazy at all. I think it's absolutely one possible
future, and I think
it comes back down to this question of trust.
How do we roll that out in a way where
those running the study or in the medical practice
trust it to put in front of the patients, and the patients trust it?
And not every patient is going to want that, right?
So, what does it look like in the meantime, where you're doing
part of this
live and part of this through agentic
AI? But yeah, I think the thoughtful and
tasteful use of technology within our
structures to advance our goals is absolutely what we should
be doing, and it's coming.
Deb, final word.
Right.
No pressure.
So,
I think agentic AI, it's here, it's coming, it's getting better
so fast. It will do more and more and more of this.
I don't know if it's going to solve the last mile problem
because I think the trust problem is so profound and so
core. And I feel like there's a
certain point at the end of the day that's about values
clarification, and
Ellie, if you're telling me to go on a clinical trial,
I want you to know me as a human. And
if 95% of it is done by agentic AI, I don't need you
to order
all the tests, the MRI. I don't even need you to interpret the MRI.
I don't even need you to have looked at the MRI, but I
think there's still going to be a human in the middle.
It's just that we may get crowded out.
Maybe we'll just be sitting with patients and talking about
their families and their dogs.
But I don't think it's going to take over completely.
More and more? Yes. Really quickly? Yes.
It's going to be our partner, but I think the trust issue is so profound.
So maybe that makes me a Luddite. Maybe it's generational, and we
need a whole...
There's a lot of conversation about digital natives, people who are just born
digital. I think for people who weren't born digital, we won't
see that. Maybe the next generation that was born with
agentic AI, it'll be acceptable to them in a way that those
of us who were born without agentic AI may just never quite get
there.
What a way to end it.
So thanks again to this outstanding panel.
Thanks to those of you sticking around till the end.
And we really appreciate all the participation and engagement.
Take care, everyone.
It really is.
I loved your slides.
Oh, I love them too.
Your slides are so good